[Music]
nice one jake
welcome back to the quarter digital
podcast everybody ladies and gentlemen
boys and girls um who do we got here
today we got the
uh the fabled the infamous nico
perringer
nico say hi hi we've got the
ever talented and charming clinton jones
always charming and armed talented yes
yes
and of course we have the undeniable
the charismatic the eighth wonder of the
world ren wyken
the eighth yeah i got a question for you
guys
at what point like how old do you have
to get what age do you reach when you
start clapping on
one and three versus two and four
what you know it's like having a good
time having a good time
yes two and four yeah and then when you
get so old you're like having a good
time
it sounds so clunky the other way like
how old you have to be to like
hit that is there a transition is that
an age thing uh yeah once you turn 40.
once you turn 40 that's when yeah was i
doing that when i was like no no no
no no jacob's playing the banjo we were
on the twos and fours feeling good yeah
okay i was i was doing the the because i
know you were on the offbeat from me
yes yeah but i did when you like start
doing this
yeah yeah yeah specifically yeah you
have that like
you don't really know how to do anything
and you're just like kind of awkwardly
yeah
like i think it's like 65 you know
i think it's sooner than that i think 55
i'm calling it 55.
yeah when you just cut out one of them
and just hit on the ones
having a good time well that's like
that's like a build-up that's like a
start to a build-up
you know if you when you get younger is
it just like a like the beginning of
like a drop like from a dubstep song's
like
clap clap clap clap clap
yeah yeah i think that's uh i think
that's about right i think we've solved
it for everyone here
so as soon as i start clapping on the
one and three like unintentionally you
can put me down
yeah like call you like install you no
no no like okay you can kill me
okay got it yeah you know what's crazy
it's december it's the embarrassment
it's december
right now you're right yeah it is it's
the tenth month of the year guys
december
yes is it deceptive this december was
the tenth month of the year before
julius caesar and augustus came yeah i
was about to say is july and august got
added in there and
threw everything off mm-hmm yeah yeah
dec
that's what it means that's so the same
reason why
october october yeah it's ten and not
eight
it used to be the eighth month of the
year october i didn't know that
so which ones i'm kind of disappointed
it was august and july because they were
named after the the romans the famous
julia julius caesar july well do they
also just discover that 10 months didn't
fit within a year
i don't remember yeah i you know they
were really into tens you know they had
the whole like really trying to figure
out
renewable things tender please don't ask
us to write anything to a billion
because that's gonna be real
hard for us um but they were obsessed
with tens
so i know that you know a year is
basically based on the cycles of the
moon
um well i mean a year is based on one
full revolution
viewers based on one full revolution
around the sun which happens to more or
less coincide with 12. so that's crazy
right it's coincidence yeah
it's almost exactly awesome i can't
remember what it is but basically it's
like
it's like a quarter day offset so that's
why every four years you have a whole
day that you make up for the leap year
the leap year yeah yeah um yeah but why
is time
and for that matter like circles why is
that all base six
what do you mean base six like time line
time is not measured in lines it's why
clocks are round
yeah don't you know that don't you know
that
no but like thank you you have 16
minutes to us
to an hour you have 60 seconds to a
minute it's base
you know six oh it wasn't that all just
like this is convenient
like it's like these numbers fit like
this is like you could chop it up any
way you want
like why 360 degrees why is it not just
like 100 degrees in a circle
oh man i could totally answer this if i
just had like a couple hours to just
like sit down and research it but
i don't have it fresh in my memory okay
okay here like the known truth
is that the earth takes 365 days to go
around the sun right uh yeah that is
how long we have declared it
yes 365 yeah it's not exact it's not
expected
it brings us to the same point more or
less that's the marketable number
yeah 365 days a year yeah it's actually
365 in
like a quarter okay so neil neil
degrasse tyson explained this he said
that the leap year
he said that the gregorian calendar that
we currently use
uh it it it believe the year and the
the 12 months and the 24 hours and the
365 that whole thing
is the most precise that we've been able
to do
so far because apparently the amount
that it's off by
when we accommodate for the leap year is
so minuscule
that it's it's something like hundreds
of thousands of years from now
it'll be off by like a day wow dude
that's a movie that's a movie when it's
like when you hit that moment like
it's like wait a second a day has
escaped us like where did that day go
a hundred thousand years later
well i hope to see some clarifications
in the comments about more specifics
to this yeah i'm sure if you guys know
exactly how precise this is please let
us know because we don't
but uh from what we've heard it's pretty
precise
so anyway december yeah not only is it
the 10th month of the year
it's also a perfect calendar but it also
brings up a perfect time
to consider you know what you've done
that year
and really what is it about the next
year that you want to
do better or do differently um and you
know clint i know you're pretty
uh introspective guy um you know have
you
have you thought about that at all this
year yet uh
are you still kind of formulating your
plans and your thoughts
um both yeah both okay like christmas
time i mean
i i do gather thoughts throughout the
year um you got me hooked on trello jake
so i've been using that um to like
clint's the one keeping the
recorder trello hashtag not sponsored
not sponsored that's true
um but no no i i do like enjoy tracking
goals and stuff and and
having whatever program you want to use
um
to do that is is nice and i do have like
a to-do list on there that's just a
forever to-do list
and then it's broken down month week day
and then there's a completed one
um so oh you you cross them over into
the completed category that's the best
part dude
that's the freaking best part it's the
reward just delete them
delete when i'm done with them yeah
cause here's the thing like you just
said jake like
um you know you go over what you've
accomplished in the year so like i'll
scroll through my completed
list and be like what did i like really
complete like take out the trash like
whatever but like um you know make a
website or sell prints or whatever you
know like it's like yeah that was like a
yeah
a moment you know like it took time to
get to that point um
yeah but yeah it's like a mix i i have
things i want to do
i've still think about it too like
christmas break for me is a really good
time to get away
and just like catch up on things that i
know
i've wanted to catch up on like one
punch man like i've never seen one punch
man i need to watch one punch yeah
it's a sequel two punch man
make a joke about putting ketchup on
things because he said you want to catch
up on things anyways
our minds are chickens by the way i
looked at the base6 thing
can we pull this back for a second i
wondered why you're on your phone
because this is crazy what is it it's
not base six it's base
60. so sexagemal
sexagesimal
also known as base 60 or sex again a
rare
sex secondary sorry it's it's really
sick
you're making sound boring it's pretty
sexy man
stop talking so stop speaking so sexy
it's a numeral system with
60 as its base it originated with the
ancient sumerians and the third
millennium
bc was passed down to the ancient
babylonians so smart
and is still used in a modified form for
measuring time angles and geographic
coordinates
here's why the number 60 is a superior
highly composite number ooh it has 12
factors
with so many factors many fractions
involving a sexagesimal number are
simplified
for example one hour can be divided
evenly
into sections of 30 minutes 20 minutes
15 minutes 12 minutes 10 minutes six
minutes five minutes four minutes three
minutes two minutes and one minute
60 is the smallest number that is
divisible by every number
from one to six so you said twelve
divisions it has twelve twelve factors
twelve factors
dang so they would like okay that makes
sense yeah that makes sense
it would be hard if an hour was 27
minutes you'd be like
yeah can you meet me at a half hour but
they said
yeah so if you're if your math system
doesn't have decimals yet you need to
express things in parts of something
60 is the lowest thing in which you can
easily express different parts of it
that are even
without decimals wow crazy and they did
that 5 000 years ago
well no it was 300 bc sub b oh i thought
you said the third millennium bc
twenty twenty three hundred years is the
third millennium hold up
i i you're right third millennium bc
now that was like five thousand years
ago 5000 years ago that's like
not that much longer after writing was
invented
i can't even like comprehend that far
back
i can barely comprehend like the last
generation like uh
yeah there's like archival footage of
stuff okay i can imagine it
uh i love that like writing was invented
so that we could share recipes for beer
really more or less like there but like
uh it was like a form of accounting and
also a way to like
keep track of like the the wheat and uh
grains that you know they were farming
and also like how to brew beer because
beer was like
the beverage of choice back then no one
really drank water because it kind of
made you sick
everyone drank beer yeah yeah this is
the part we started talking about snow
crash and how
writing sumerians and babylon yeah and
how writing and language is invented to
create a way of mind control the peons
and have them follow your orders
yeah it's one of the best books i've
ever read so that author wrote another
book called seven eves i've recommended
this to you you gotta read it he also
wrote neuromancer
wait wait different nope just kidding
not that guy i'm wrong that's william
gibson
who wrote snow crash neil stephen
stevenson yeah yes yeah
neuromancer was so con like have you
guys read neuromancer no
okay yeah i i had to i had to like cliff
notes
every chapter after i read it because
like what the heck just happened and
it's supposed to be like a sick like
there's this character who's literally
trinity
you know before like trinity yeah help
neuromancer
nope it's just very confusing but yeah
snow crash
kevin senzaki recommended that book to
me and it blew my mind dude it's the
best book ever it's
it's really good it's really good i want
to read it maybe i'll read it over this
break because so many great funny
it's kind of like remember the da vinci
code yeah and angels and demons that i
thought was a little bit better i loved
angels and demons a lot more than
division
you know how like it took all these real
life things and like gave a little bit
of a spin so it could be a fun
conspiracy thing yeah yeah
that's what snow crashes with like the
ideas
of like vr the metaphor was written in
1992 right
as well as like language in society and
how people function it's really cool
dude it's groundbreaking like
he's coming up with stuff like the
metaverse where you're like there's a
central hub and everyone like chills
here and but it's like
the vr bodies are passing through each
other and they're just clipping and
stuff there's clipping and then like
um you know like you it's all these like
stock models there's one of them's name
is clint is like the stock model
this is like a stock dude and then
there's like a like a
jennifer or something i think we buried
we took this dude
out of this 30 year old book and buried
him in a microwave in the backyard
because of your stock 3d model yeah yeah
i want to read that book uh i really
enjoyed his other book called seven
eaves it was about like
what happens like the book literally
opens with the moon exploding
okay no one knows why intro and and
they're like oh that sucks
and then like scientists figure out oh
yeah all that debris from the moon is
gonna start raining down on the planet
in about two years and once it does that
everyone on earth is going to die
so it's a mad rush just to kind of get
as many people up into
space as possible and then like the hard
rain comes
and that's the first third of the book
the second third of the book
is what happens once earth is destroyed
and the
last remnants of humanity are in space
trying to like
yeah because humanity is humanity
there's drama there's
challenges and it's not good and then
the last third of the book
is 5 000 years in the future after like
earth has been like settled down most i
don't want to say anything more
to spoil it what most authors would just
write three books but i love it when
they just
like no this is one story i'm gonna make
it one story and the crazy thing is that
like it's the same characters in the
first two thirds
of the book but then the last third it's
a completely new story
a new set of characters is a very bold
decision and a lot of people weren't
really fans of that
but i found it really fascinating
because it i almost want to make a video
about this because it has some of the
most
interestingly accurate portrayals of how
like space
civilization could be with current
understanding of physics
they have like this scorpion tail thing
like it's this space station that goes
around the world and they have like this
giant long
scorpion tail that unravels as it's
moving and it's able to grab stuff
off the ground and just you only got
like a minute maybe last 30 seconds
or you can actually you can actually
walk onto this thing from the ground
and then you get slingshotted into space
so it's because
yeah it's very much like a tether but
it's like it's it's
it's very fascinating and uh all of it
is based in
very real science it's very hard sci-fi
so it's like there's no like
well if we just kind of do this we can
do it that way and it's like no this is
how it works
kind of like the martian was it's very
much like the martian yeah
yeah it was a very good book i don't
know how we got onto this tangent you
guys started talking about
sumerians babylonians sumerians and
writing
like it's just like yeah i i could keep
thomas no crash i'm sorry
did the kayaking bit too like the theory
what is that
well the the idea that people crossed i
mean this one's probably
probably made up probably but it's fun
to pretend it's not
the idea that people cross the ocean by
basically surfing on swells
and that's how you cover the long
distances in a canoe or a kayak oh whoa
okay
yeah some giant giant slow-moving waves
there's an inuit assassin in
snow crash that travels by viacom so i
read the first chapter of snow crash
and i i stopped because one i was
listening to the book and
the narrator was kind of wonky and he
kept talking about pizza and like
driving this car
really fast i get that now but i was
just like
what am i listening to this is weird i
turned it off and i never opened it
again
that was like six years ago the main bad
guy his name's raven
he drives a motorcycle and in the
passenger seat in the sidecar
is a nuclear bomb yeah
and it's wired up to his heartbeat it's
yep so if you kill him
the bomb goes on wait wait wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait
he's gotta go he's gotta go everywhere
he's gotta go hauling around this
nuke yeah this is the bad guy yeah yeah
because this is protection against like
if you kill me
you kill yourself it's my number what if
he needs to what if he needs to get off
the motorcycle
no you can't it's wired to his heartbeat
so it's like it's like it's like a
bracelet
wireless it's like wireless yeah or it's
like an implant he has wait is this the
pizza delivery
bad guy oh what if he what if he goes
out of range
then it goes off he's a he's a walker
what if he has to reset the wi-fi and he
goes off he doesn't care man he's a
madman he doesn't he doesn't live for
tomorrow
dude glass vibes yeah he's he would love
to see that nuke go off
we've given away too much yeah i want to
read this book
i'll try to read over the break i'm
finishing up uh the fourth stormlight
archive book right now which is a book
i've been waiting for for three years i
got it the day it came out
i'm like literally in the final 10
percent and you've read you've read at
least one sanderson book you've read
mistborn
and he's known for having some of the
most intense like
last chunks of a book ever it even has a
name it's called the avalanche
the sander the sander lance
i'm right at the beginning of the
avalanche of this book and literally the
only thing i want to do is continue
reading this book but i can't
are you saving it for christmas break no
i'm saving it for the moment i get out
of this podcast
[Laughter]
like i'm not emotionally ready to tackle
it right now i have to go somewhere so i
can like let my emotions run free
i need to yeah writing
writing is critic pretty incredible i
mean you think about
you think about 5 000 years ago then
people just writing down
ones and zeros do we have wheat or no
wheat okay it's
this is this is for wheat this is for no
wheat
okay got it and then you know through
the process of that
multiply that by 5 000 years and you get
written history and then just segue that
right into ones and zeroes for
digitization of everything
that right into code yeah
and once again it's the time in the
podcast where i tell you about today's
sponsor storyblocks that's right
they are the one-stop shop for all of
your stock asset
needs whether that's b-roll motion
graphics after effects templates
sound effects storyblocks has you
covered whether it's a commercial
project
a video for youtube or just a video for
yourself everything on there is in
beautiful 4k
they have such an extensive library of
content on there you will never
find or need to use the same thing twice
it's constantly being updated
storybox is going to have what you need
if you're looking to add another layer
of quality and professionalism to
everything that you're doing so head on
over to storyblocks.com
hey that's they're calling me about
storybox do you hear that
hey yeah storyblocks.com corridor cast
is going to be the place
where you're going to get everything you
need so go on there get an unlimited
all-access plan
once again that's storyblocks.com
corridor
cast all right see you out there oh okay
the telemarketer hung up on me
but seriously guys storyblocks.com
corridor cast
that's where you're gonna go to find
this awesome tool that we use around
here let's get back to the podcast
um to you know continue with books here
i read a book the reason why i brought
that up is because i read this book
called like the history of the world in
six drinks
and it was like basically it started off
with like how
or the book is about how civilization is
literally
uh driven by these six drinks
and it started off with beer and then i
believe it went into
wine i think i'm getting the order kind
of wrong here in the early ones and then
it went to uh
like hard alcohol like rum in like the
the seven seas or whatever
you know uh then it went to
[Music]
coffee i believe or tea one of those two
is coffee and then tea or is tea then
coffee i forget the order
but then lastly it was coca-cola what
those are the most important drinks in
the history of humankind wow
so so um beer
and wine are the original rudimentary
uh assets if you will the
the raw material that you need to make
uh
to make spirits yeah to make brandy and
and whiskey
uh respectively that's that's brandy is
a wine base
and and you know beer is a wheat base a
rye base
um so that's those are the two sort of
bases that that
hard alcohol came from they were like
hey you know this beer is pretty good
but what if we took a bunch of beer and
condensed it into a single beer
that would be even better and that's
that's basically what happened and then
yeah
coffee um i i i don't know what's older
ren
coffee or tea but i do know it
maybe but coffee's also really old
coffee i was surprised to learn how old
coffee was i think coffee is older
because tea kind of started becoming a
big deal
um with like india and whatnot uh like
the
i feel like china has been on t forever
well yeah i mean china yeah and the far
east
obviously they had that figured out from
day one
not gonna lie i also use this book as my
uh
go to sleep book oh it's time for me to
go to sleep i'm gonna start reading this
book
uh t beats coffee by guess how much
two years no 500 years no a month dude
no because they're like if i can put
this leaf in a
in hot water i can put this bean a day a
day
a cherry a cherry
are you talking like when it was tea
pre-dates coffee by four thousand five
hundred years
okay so that also creates oh they got
beat by quite a bit
wow yeah but i don't think t
was like the the economic force it was
until much later
because probably t was like a huge deal
like companies and nations were built
around the idea of trading teams yeah
the india tea company yeah
great britain and the lots of lots of
yeah
yeah they also liked their um what was
that stuff called
that they got opium opium yeah they got
they liked that quite a bit
uh yeah i guess coffee is the second
most
uh globally distributed product
um or it's like right near the top
behind oil
oh really uh it's it's pretty remarkable
how that's
come onto the scene over the last 500
years
or so whatever it needs a caffeine bump
i guess yeah well tea's got caffeine too
true but it's a different
like energy you know that you get from
tea when i drink tea i'm like i don't
feel like i'm like
but when i drink coffee i'm definitely
like you know
do you like being like no no i don't
it's like very
do you drink tea or coffee i drink
coffee jake do you drink tea or coffee
i drink both mostly coffee clint
both does one more than the other i like
the
taste of coffee better but i like the
feeling
of tea better christian do you drink tea
or coffee
coffee from christian interesting
i don't drink any that's good yeah it's
like
i just never liked the flavor of coffee
i i've always
enjoyed the smell of coffee but for the
longest time like literally just
about a year or two ago i started
actually enjoying drinking coffee
uh never was a big fan also i
i am lactose intolerant so like creamer
always just
was bad for my system until i learned
that like almond beverage
actually works really well well it's
like can't say almond milk
cancelled dude um
what is it wait why can't you say almond
milk because the
the milk lobbies big milk forced
uh big milk cheese
dude big almond milk isn't a milk
our milk
putting down everybody else yeah for
their cheese
and their milk that's for yours and
their ice cream
wait did they actually like take him to
court and saying you can't brand it
no they made it was like a legislation
like it was a oh there's like one of
those european kind of things
like it can only be called champagne
when it comes from champagne
in france you're like actually yeah it
was because
you know big milk they had the money to
spend to get the legislation passed
if you could if in california i don't
know if that's
nationwide what a waste of time sorry
sorry sorry i'm done i'm done i'm done
i'm done if you could visualize milk
as a person what would they look like
you
no no uh
baymax yeah yeah all right i just say
the michelin man but it's like he's too
too bumpy baymax is smooth
i feel like they'd i feel like they'd be
kind of like a frumpy white dude yeah
like
like not like colonel sanders like
like a like a dude that hasn't really
been outside a whole lot you know
no they're like it's like i was like mr
clean
you know jacked maybe not so jacked just
a little bit milk makes you strong
because he's strong bones
i mean a lot of most of that is just uh
i forget the word for it something about
uh uh tart like
not tarp uh what do you call fake grass
turf turf turf griff
anyway so um milk astroturfing
yeah it's like it's just like so much of
that is just like it's not actually real
benefits of milk it's just
the companies that have been advertising
that for years um
i totally lost my train of thought with
what i was trying to go for there though
are you saying that it doesn't actually
make your bones strong
yeah like no it might not be more
calcium once your bones stop growing at
like 22.
i mean you need some calcium but you
don't need like the mouth oh no i was
gonna say uh
i saw this tweet that uh was really
interesting it was one of those like
four
picture panel things of like these
psychopaths from movies drinking milk
and it's like you know you got the dude
from uh was it
the the i'm awful at this right now oh
uh
the glorious bastards yes yes
also the the girl from get out
and uh the dude who had like that little
nail gun
a little compressed air nail gun that he
would hit he'd put it up to a person's
head
no country for old men that's his name
javier
yeah his name was like shock shockeed or
something like that
what was his name in the movie khan
they all have a scene where they drink
milk and it's creepy
dude when he like looks in the tv from
that movie yeah you remember known
country where he like sits down
and he like pops some milk and he's like
sugar and sugar
sugar yeah and town sugar and he just
sits in uh
in what's his name's house i barely
remember the movie to be honest oh my
god he sits in the main character's
house and he just drinks milk and he
sits on the couch
yeah and then he leaves and then tommy
lee jones is the detective hunting down
and he rolls up five minutes later and
he sits on the couch and he looks at
like there's a shot when anton shakur
was in the house there was a shot of him
in the reflection of the tv that was
turned off it was like distorted and
creepy
and when tommy jones comes in five
minutes later he sees the glass of milk
and it's still cold
oh yeah and he looks at the tv and his
and it's tommy lee jones's reflection
the tv and he's like
dude he was so close he was so close to
catching this guy
oh man that movie is a masterpiece it is
it's wonderful it's a great modern
western
one of the few yeah i'm getting chills
just thinking about it man it's so good
luellen moss yeah they really got the
names right in that one
you know like uh like an old country boy
from texas named lou ellen
when he's hunting and he you know
he's a hunter right so it's the movie's
about two hunters hunting each other you
know in different ways
and yeah um the beginning of the movie
like he's wrapping up his little hunt
and then he comes across all of these
like lifted trucks in the middle of the
like desert
in texas i think and they're in a circle
and he just sees there's bullets and
bodies and
gut and like guts and blood and cocaine
and
he's like oh my god and he finds
uh up by this tree a guy who got away
and he's like chained to a briefcase and
he pops it and it's full of like two
million dollars and he's like
he takes it two million dollars on a
briefcase yeah or a million or whatever
and then he goes home he starts sleeping
and then he wakes up middle of the night
because there was a guy who was alive he
was like water and water
you know and he left him there and he
wakes him up he's like god dang it
and he goes back and he brings water and
oh yeah i remember that yeah he brings
him the water and he's gone
and then he sees headlights come up over
the ridge just like at midnight just
these trucks looking over and he looks
and he sees like his truck
these new trucks they're like popping
his tires and he's like oh crap
and then it goes from there dude it's so
good this is so good
you know it is it's it's it's great and
it's cohen brothers directed
and produced yeah that's a classic
gotta watch it again now there's some
there's some like directors writers and
uh dps that you just want them to stay
together and make movies until
they're dead yeah you know cohen
brothers roger deakins they should just
shoot things together forever
uh was it andrew garland or whatever
like i did sicario
[Music]
i thought so i'm pretty sure we'd have
to just look up some like interview with
him
that sounds better
um yeah deacons as well yeah ideally
those two
i do those two always shoot movies
together forever they're on a roll
and it's like it's like um atticus ross
and trent resident should always do
movies
with um crap david fincher david fincher
yeah yeah
always forever so good dude trent reznor
did the soundtrack for the watchmen show
really yeah it was good it was very good
very good show very good soundtrack
man they're so good yeah the 10 inch
nails
now question maybe everybody's opinion
is different
is it fingernails or carpentry nails
huh what nine inch nails
wait i i probably know what it is now i
think about oh i see what you're saying
oh like i actually don't know
i always assumed they were real nails
and just really big nails but carpentry
nails
yes and as opposed to figuring out it i
i see what you're saying is it a
biblical reference
does the reference like how big the
nails were that they used like
maybe dude metal band names or maybe
it's like a railroad deal
that would be a total metal band name
thing to do yeah it'd be a really metal
thing
or maybe it's just a railroad reference
let me see
he's really into railroads and he used
to build him
really into carpentry yeah okay you're
right
yeah the other rumored okay this is a
rumored explanation alleging that
reznor's choice
to reference jesus's crucifixion with
nine inch spikes
or freddy krueger's nine inch
fingernails i i think maybe that's all
part of the same
same origin like even though it's a good
name for a band
is it i think so i think it's great it
seems a little random tonight
and then um alliteration
going true it does sound edgy
do you when people ask you so like what
kind of music you're into you're like
nin bro and then
real men and you're like yeah yeah you
ever heard of them
nin they stand under a street lamp uh
anything else you're like no just just
nine inch nails
none that's it does resin or his last
name
because that also sounds like a made up
like my name is trent
rezner that's with the z it's too cool
for the band 9-inch nails
or nin well i was surprised to learn
just how many people in hollywood
have fake names yeah like that's crazy
all of them
yeah such an accepted thing that once
you go into like becoming an actor and
you get like an agent you get assigned a
new name that actually sounds good
yeah and like it rolls off the tongue
looks good on the credits
everyone and it's just like i i remember
seeing a couple actors like oh yeah no
this is my stage name or like this is my
hollywood name and i'm just like wait
what that's not your real name
it's like but no one knows the real name
like mike diva
well i mean that's a little different
but he kind of he talks about like he's
like yeah
you know i should have picked something
else than a diva
but you know it does roll off the tongue
really well i i still call him mike diva
as opposed to just mike
something about it just it does stick
with him really well yeah and same with
some of the others he's such a diva
like in uh in in due date when uh
robert downey jr and zach galifianakis
and zach elephant axis characters like
yeah
well ethan tremblay is not my real name
that's my stage name
my real name's ethan chase and he's like
wait
ethan chase ethan chase is a way better
name
is that the movie where he like lets his
father's ashes go
yeah and they blow back into his face
yeah
yeah and then they and then they drink
them in the coffee yeah with jamie foxx
yes yeah that's such a good movie man
like it's such a good comedy zack
alfanac is is so
funny man what what a character did you
guys watch the between two ferns movie
and netflix yeah
yeah did you like it it wasn't good i
actually liked it but really just
because
i got some more of the between two ferns
parts and the bloopers are funny
you do keanu reeves right yeah
yeah i mean the interviews are the best
part you know yeah that's all i wanted
to see they were funny
did that start as like a comedy central
show or
was that just online or how where did
that start funny or die
isn't that comedy okay will ferrell's
guys will ferrell started actually
you're right okay totally right yeah and
didn't funny or die just recently
die did they get bought out i thought
they went under
like i thought i thought some i thought
i saw some news about funny or die going
under recently
like in the last half year that would be
sad yeah you're right it didn't start on
funny or die
when you're done sounds like the
internet from 15 years ago
yeah black or albino black sheep it's
like about a black sheep eboom's world
something awful funny or die like it
falls right into that
five second films yeah yeah
yep the internet of lore
i miss the internet of war the internet
of war
is it is it the lore of yore and maybe
it's of your oh maybe it's a viewer yeah
you're right
but they're also there's the lore too
that's yeah
that's that's why i said all right so to
change topics a little bit guys
i kind of want to talk about our year in
review slash what we want to do next
year
oh man this is a big topic i know
seriously a little bit a little bit
so yeah usually at the beginning of
every year we have like a meeting where
we kind of like
discuss our goals for the year like what
kind of things do we want to focus on
uh in the content that we create and
this year uh rather
last year so 2019 i was like all right
i'm gonna make all these science videos
i'm going to make a bunch of them i'm
going to make it one
every single month and i proceeded to
make seven and the dirty dozen the dirty
dozen yeah there's the
the sneaky seven elite eight
yeah yeah the naughty friends the
ninety-nine
and that was just because like i
couldn't make them all because to make
12 it would have to be like my full-time
thing
uh so yeah so then this year my goal was
to
focus more on uh drone content and 3d
printing content
i'd say i pretty successfully did both
of those things but
lately like the last month or so we've
been working on functional filmmaking
you guys have both already filmed your
parts i'm filming my part tomorrow
but in making this the script for
functional filmmaking which is about how
i make those
those videos of your uh it got me really
like
i want to make more of those again so
maybe next year i'll make more they're
so good man
like they're really good you are the
like vfx bill nye
really like really that's a high
compliment it's legit
no no seriously that's a great price
they're so much fun to watch
and i just want to see more and i will
help you do the effects on every single
one
how how many balloons would it really
take to lift the house from up
that's a really good thing that's great
i want to do that one yeah nobody steals
that idea please no i'm already working
on it i've got a script written i'm
already like in pre-production
no no like yeah i finished that first
one just makes a video
and then you hit play just like 5624 and
that's the end of the video a lot of
views
it'd probably get a lot of views it's
just like how to microwave bread
you just stand there for 20 seconds and
then you just say 5
624 and the video abruptly ends
yeah so that's one one thing i want i
want to make more of those videos again
i miss doing them because i only made
one video this year and that was the one
right at the beginning of quarantine
talking about exponential growth talking
about covid
spread that stuff but the other thing i
really want to get into
is learning unreal engine i think it's
time i think it's time
to get into the real-time rendering
workplace yes that is certainly a goal
of mine i
um i actually started this year earlier
this year i started and
it oh my god okay so this this actually
happened to me
like eight years ago wha you got turned
into an unreal engine
oh no no no i i was in a predicament
where
i started out my first 3d program i ever
learned was cinema 4d
and well not the very first but it was
the first legit one and
there were no good c4d tutorials
anywhere on the internet
and i was actually making c40 tutorials
for like uh
cg tuts yeah yep um i remember seeing
your tests on ae testplus.com
yeah and like i was just
bummed out that like all these sick
tutorials are for 3ds max i'm like god
screw 3d smacks they got all the good
tuts like why can't c4 do you get the
good tats
and i eventually ended up dropping c4d
giving up on it going to 3ds max and
switching to 3ds max because you guys
were on 3ds max and you guys had a lot
to teach me
um well them i wasn't on 3ds max at that
time i got on 3ds max because you guys
were on 3ds that's what i'm saying yeah
um like in hindsight it's like oh man i
could have done like the video go pilot
but
for c4d but that's greyscale gorilla you
know
um and i the point of the story is i
quit because there weren't any good tuts
and that's what happened
with me in unreal it's very hard to say
that i quit i i
i stopped you you moved on you're like
you shoved it you shoved it i shelved it
but it's something i definitely want to
get good at it's like the qixel rebirth
if you guys don't know what that is like
look it up right now watch it you know i
know i know i know holy crap that's so
good
and then memories of australia is yes
that's another amazing one
that blew me away i couldn't believe
that that was like
it was so unreal
wow you're the jet the dad jokes are
strong in this episode ladies and
gentlemen
right now you guys have news to share
with us
if all you guys get into unreal
like i think there's gonna be some magic
next year
with that the main inspirations for me
for yeah for for
like learning unreal one obviously just
the stagecraft we've started seeing with
the mandalorian
like being able to have like an led wall
behind you and then like real time
rendering and all that stuff that's like
in my opinion the coolest
technology leap in the last couple
decades as far as like filmmaking goes
uh but more than that i'm like i'm
getting into i'm really getting into vr
and i want to make like
vr experiences i want to meld some sort
of way to turn like
filmmaking or something into like a vr
experience i don't exactly know how to
do that yet or even what that really
means like i even
started experimenting with like 3d video
i put like a 3d camera on my drone and
flew it around i showed you that was a
trip
yeah and it's like it works really well
uh
you have to kind of have a strong
stomach uh for some of the things i was
doing but
i don't know i wonder if there's a way i
can expand on that so right now i'm
gonna try to see if i can learn how to
make just like simple
this simple game a simple interface in
vr using unreal
and hopefully just the more things i do
with that the more opportunities open
for the things that we can make
just like the mocap suit like we got
yeah a tool and then you use it and you
make
a video with it you know and of course
sam has been like the pioneer for unreal
here at the studio this year he's
he's been working away he's working on
avatar two right now he took it away
from james cameron
snatched it yeah snatched
yeah um i mean no ren like if that's
something you guys uh
cause what what i could see happening is
like we could
collectively make something like that
and then you know we could
we could put it out as a piece of
content we could put it out as a game
like there's a there's a number of
different eventual
distribution mediums for it yeah i mean
obviously and then obviously we have
uh the um
the entire green light show that's that
we need to
well we're gonna it hasn't been greenlit
yet but
the local zero show like in about two
more months that thing's going to get
greenlit too
and so there's a whole journey of
creative
stuff that needs to happen there so i
don't want to say much because it's
still
super early days but so uh peter has
spent the last like two or three weeks
like crash coursing hard through unreal
he's getting pretty good at it
he's got like a little fps game that
he's made um
but so between him sam and the three of
us
uh we might make a game
but it's a maybe it's a maybe but sam
has a really good idea game jam game i
should just mention
not like a let's sit down for eight
months and grind out like no it's va
initially initially who knows what the
future the idea sam has
is is i'm not going to say it but like
it's it's the idea is that it's simple
and he
and i don't know i don't want to say
more sam's ideas
you take the universe all right now
imagine you can be anywhere
in that universe procedural planets
procedural characters everything
computer generated
your you dream it you can live it that's
sam's idea for the game
i mean it's not in a couple weeks but uh
yeah i don't know i i feel like with all
of your guys experience with node and
playing games and and all that i think
sam has some really interesting ideas
that should be fairly easy to implement
into a game format
but in a way that we can just do it we
don't have to wait for someone else to
make it and we can maybe make something
distributed on the website
more you know yeah yeah i mean that's
that's how we've got
we've gotten thus far this far just
doing that to begin with so
i i see no reason to stop now just
because it's maybe not necessarily will
fit into four
four corners of a video yeah
well they come out with the five corner
screen next year too yeah the
well the five corner video is really the
next thing you know
just like the just like the the triangle
monitor
was was 2019 yeah and then and then
i've seen that every year um
ratio have you guys seen those shrimp
aspect ratio videos yeah
yeah those things are freaking crazy my
favorite are the easter eggs that
that creators will put into the fingers
of the shrimp
oh the easter eggs yeah like the little
storey easter eggs that aren't in the
center of the shrimp body but like are
on the
you know the fringes yes exactly yeah
yeah they're small
exactly yeah they're there it was it was
really expensive but i have a 4k
shrimp shaped monitor that's actually
coming to my house
what you got one yeah i well i got in
early
um honestly before that those are before
before they ran out of the supply
you know and then when the demand spiked
what's the frame rate on that uh
i think it's i think the refresh rate's
like 150
350 hertz nice yeah
so you know pretty great i think 60
60 frames a second you know 90 whatever
90 frames a second
whatever i don't know it doesn't matter
dude i kind of i kind of want to legit
and just track it in and just like it's
like in the background no it's like
i'm at my computer in a crew video and
i'm just talking about like this and i
just like
comp in a shrimp screen you know well
you know you know what we could do
is is you could like you could gaff tape
a regular monitor
into a shrimp shape and then like put
tracking markers on it and erase the
rest of it
yeah yeah i feel like there's a game a
version of boulder dash where you just
list off goofy gear and so you get to
guess if it's real or fake and then the
person's like no it's real or you know
whatever
oh man pull up on b h like all right so
this piece of gear
will keep your hands warm when you are
holding a boom pole
it's like real effect this sounds like
the
digit warmer yeah it sounds like a good
one
short film do you remember back in the
day when we used to make corridor shorts
yeah
yeah i do man remember mudface
yeah man that feels like it was so long
ago it was it was january
i know but it's still as fun this year
this year though still like that
that's from the current era the channel
but that feels like
it feels like there's another era long
ago it seriously does
i mean a lot has happened since in
restaurants i was gonna suggest
that uh that you guys get together maybe
on like friday
uh because there's some like clint wren
peter
nico i think you might have some time i
was gonna suggest you guys get together
and start brainstorming
for some some ideas for next year i do
have an idea
for tether for the website it's been a
minute since anyone's really had a
proper brainstorming session
no i don't mean the beast actually i
mean i mean tether og tether
nice yeah but that's for another time we
got we got some shows to make first
so but like the beast is the beast over
is that like the beast is over for now
for now that means it's over yeah over
for now
i mean it's a script you know you never
know
it's in that dusty shelf from the back
of the closet
well the other thing the other reason
why we should do that and not just for
corridor videos but also for
website ideas like yeah a lot of times a
lot of
like all the stuff that's on the website
currently is all stuff that we've sort
of had
floating around in the ether of the idea
verse
uh you know in some shape or form that
we've pulled
into this the site and so
just the process of like spitballing
and and picking out ideas that you like
oftentimes
you know the test of time proves whether
those ideas are like good or not if you
keep coming back to them and and you
keep liking them and
and usually they find they find their
way to something
uh at some point or another so i just
think it's a healthy process
yeah absolutely gotta keep those brain
brain juices flowing
then brain cells moving boys gotta keep
them brain cells moving
but okay what about you guys what what
are your hopes for next year
my hopes for next year definitely get
good with unreal i want to get to the
point where i can
get that quicksilver rebirth or memories
of australia quality down
oh man um for me
reasoning is less that i want to make a
game
but more um the fact that if i can
create
a photo reel environment uh from scratch
or it could be any environment i would i
don't have to physically go there like
it's so good for like matte paintings or
like uh
you know establishment shots that kind
of stuff so like the whole reason i got
into 3d was because
if i could think of it then i can make
it and yeah if i
if i have the technical info or the
technical know-how
then there's literally nothing stopping
me so that's why i want to learn is like
to just
expand the ability to tell any story
possible um and also i love just
beautiful art like beautiful landscapes
it's like
dude it gets me amped it gets me sewing
i want to make a video where i'm
standing on the moon
talking about the moon and i want to use
like unreal to
to make that happen that'd be sick i
have this i don't want to say more about
the moon idea but it's a very specific
idea
that's great you need to have you need
to have on like a buzz lightyear costume
when you do that
[Music]
buzz dude
what about you nico um
i got a couple different aspirations
honestly i
you know with corridor having grown so
much especially this year and it's been
tricky this year because obviously you
know
we haven't been in the studio for a lot
of the year um
there you know there's a vibe that
corridor had when it was like six people
you know you knew each other you were
working on projects together
it was all just like collective you know
pursuits
um and as corridor's gotten bigger
especially with not everybody being in
the studio it's hard to feel like that's
all
one thing still it's hard to feel like
it's one group of people
having a good time creating art being
passionate etc
it's still happening like you know every
thing coming out is being
led by someone who is just excelling at
what they do
but the sense of like that sense of i
guess community is a little skinny
right now i mean i guess compared to
like any regular corporate job like
there's way more sense of community
here than there but like i don't see
everybody very
like very often i see clint
probably like three of the five days of
the week you know i see ren
more often i feel like four to five of
the days of the week i see sam pretty
frequently
but like you know i see peter two days a
week i see nick for like a day and a
half like
i just i don't get to spend a lot of
time with everybody right now and i'd
like to
get back to that more like you know
get more into like bringing everybody
together and getting a feel for what we
can try to accomplish with that group
now that's like big pie in the sky like
you know overview of corridor stuff but
like
in terms of like endeavors personal
endeavors artistic endeavors
i want to get back into filmmaking
without all the burden
specific i want to get back into like
the imaginative
world building kind of filmmaking
without all the burdens that came with
that because back in the day when you
wanted to do that that meant a lot of
matte paintings and visual effects which
is kind of
you know what inspired a lot of visual
effects for myself when i got into it
but you end up spending like a week to
do like your five opening shots your
piece and
it's just it's not possible to like just
tell a cool story like
a lot of what held me back as a
filmmaker in a way was the visual
effects
in certain regards and certain ways of
telling stories it also you know greatly
accelerated other parts of my filmmaking
but it's one of those things where if
you you know if you start off learning
how to do
cool things you might miss out on how to
do good dialogue and that kind of stuff
you know i've spent a lot of time trying
to catch up on that i feel like i
finally kind of wrapped my head around
at least basic story function a little
bit more um and like
directing actors and getting what you
need from a shoot to you know get a
story told
and i feel like so many burdens have
disappeared you know everything from
like expensive cameras have disappeared
to
we have a crew like in studio now like
we don't
like there's a there's a problem like
when we were like 22 23 years old
and we were like making videos like none
of our friends had jobs yet so not a big
deal you can get together on like a
tuesday you could shoot something yeah
then once you hit like 24 25 all your
friends have careers and nobody can
shoot on like a tuesday or wednesday
only people that you can pay to come in
but you don't know any of those people
because you never work with them like
you know you gotta hire an actor or a
crew member
but like corridor now has grown to the
point where it's like now there's people
here in studio where we have a team
and we just go out and shoot stuff again
and we know enough people that do the
other things professionally
that are now close enough friends and
acquaintances that
we can pull them in at any time as well
because they do that for their job
and so you know all these burdens that
came that were preventing you know i
guess certain types of filmmaking i want
to like jump back into that filmmaking
and pursue it
um yeah yeah barter attack two
smart attack two actually just to get
specific i i want to shoot a piece on
the phone i want to shoot a piece on the
iphone 12
and just be like boom here it is i want
a world long
show well you remember the boardsman
idea yeah i kind of just want to shoot
that we
we have all these great inroads so many
people in the stunt community
and like there's this idea that we have
and it's just like it involves us the
characters
i mean we're not playing ourselves but
you know we're kind of playing ourselves
playing exaggerated versions of
ourselves right
you know but it's like and we're on our
wheels we're doing what we love we're
rolling around to la like in all these
crazy places we get to it just
captures all those special things of the
moment like that you have
and you shoot on your phone you shoot
with your friends you do a cool fight
scene like fight scenes don't involve
crazy vfx like you just shoot them and
you're done with them they're fun
like i just want to do that and like
tell a story and get it out there
and be like i'm done and move on to like
the next one
you know i don't want to be precious i
just want to shoot it and tell a cool
story and not be burdened and just i'm
gonna just create and just do that
yeah i i could i feel very similar um
there's a part of me that feels
like my first goal saying of you know
learning unreal engine but then there's
also another goal of
don't pigeonhole myself and just do vfx
because i can do vfx all day long and
it's like could be really easy
but i want to challenge myself so i i
need to
dive in and tell stories and work on
dialogue and direct stuff i feel like
i've directed anything a long time yeah
it's a bummer none of us have i haven't
directed anything well
that's not being director of photography
on the commercial like i haven't
i haven't directed anything since
tactical three i believe
yeah yeah yeah i mean the the the coven
19 thing
really threw a wrench and a lot of that
progress that we were making
up to that point um the uh
you know hopefully that some of that
stuff can start to subside next year and
those
those doors can open back up because
that's kind of like
you know that's a that's a beating heart
of a part of what we do
anyways you know and the the idea of
like okay here's
here's an idea um for a piece
uh but then here's you know a creative
challenge that we face along the way
um here's us uh reflecting on
the the good and the bad of it on the
podcast um
here's us uh you know maybe putting out
a select piece
of something or another on the website
like all of that stuff
goes into the flow of our of our overall
like content ecosystem and
you know without it and without like
those those ideas bubbling to the top
like um you know it's it's not like
we've been
as bad off as some people this year but
it has
i have seen a specific point
this year with with everything going on
where we've been
that's that's how it's directly affected
us is it's that
that sort of like okay what's the next
like boss town dynamics what's the next
like idea that we put out there that
you know is is like capturing attention
but also we're doing it in our way that
is utilizing the resources that we have
and with a little bit of that
like you know just put it out there and
and
and see and move on and and
yeah i think that's like super important
and i would love to see some of that
come back
this year as we or as we move into next
year
yeah yeah yeah yeah
there you have it
cool yeah absolutely well this started
very
eccentric from base 60 numbers
then we started talking about books i
loved it yeah finally ending
on some existential life pursuits
that's pretty much the flow of most of
these podcasts wait jake what are you
hoping to achieve next year yeah jake
what are you hoping to achieve well i
mean i kind of was was like
just stepping on it there but that's
that's effectively it like
you know like primarily um
making sure that like i mean a my
primary focus is is on the website now
like and making sure that that is doing
what we wanted to do because because
overall the whole idea behind that
site is to create a a more solid
foundation from which we can
continue to develop ideas um
and to eliminate some of that that
burden of like
oh you know how do you do it if you need
x amount of money or you need x amount
of time or you need to take the whole
crew and you need to do this for x
amount of days like
the idea is to eliminate some of that um
and and we're small right now
you know but like with each each time we
scale it
each show we put out you know each new
show that gets green lit like
it just it grows a little bit bigger and
and eventually
the the goal is to make that big enough
where
um we can just have a little bit more
financial freedom to continue to
to create things and that's that's kind
of always been the goal
uh you know like how do you how do you
free up your time to be able to do x
y and z um and and that's certainly
going to be
one of my primary focuses next year cool
yeah i'm glad we have you then i mean
yeah i'm glad to do it man it's like
i'm so happy to see that website i was
just recording a thing for daniel
earlier today uh just talking about like
how
i mean scott i don't know if people know
this yet but scott is
now uh starting in march he's coming on
full-time to work on the site oh wow wow
yeah and so this will be a two-year
journey for him
a two-year journey going from the first
time that he emailed us
in may of 2019 to basically
two years later now like seeing the
thing come to fruition seeing it go
through all the evolution
finally seeing some revenue come his way
so that he can actually start to step
away from his
his day job and and now do this
i mean think about this the guys built
the whole thing on nights and weekends
like it's pretty ridiculous when you
think about it
um so i'm super excited for that and i
feel like with
him in our corner you know the the
flexibility to like
bend and and shift the site to suit our
needs
um for what we want to create obviously
like with a
with an idea and content first mentality
on the website
i just i don't know i'm super excited
about it like you combine that
flexibility with like what you guys are
going to learn and do with unreal
um and like with you know nico's ideas
and
like it just i see the whole thing just
working really well and i just want to
keep that going
i like scott i like him i think he's
cool i'm glad to have him on board yeah
yeah for sure anyways good job scott
that's really the moral of this podcast
yeah weekends wow yeah yeah i mean
pretty much
like he would take his vacation time and
work on the site
and you know like every time he's six
hours ahead of us
or whatever in l.a or in london
so you know every time i talk to him
like in the middle of the day
it's 10 o'clock his time and he's still
grinding out
whatever he's got to do right yeah man
good stuff well thanks for listening
everybody
yeah that's our podcast yeah for today
and we'll see you guys
in next week's jake any parting message
you want for anyone
uh if you haven't gotten any merch uh it
might be sold out by the time you hear
this so
sorry um follow us on instagram
if you want to know when it comes out or
join quarterdigital.com whatever
either one's fine it's good stuff it's
christmas time
again it's time to be nice to the people
you can't stand
all year
yes that's right all right happy
december everybody we're not christmas
yet
we're not gonna say merry christmas yet
but we'll get there we'll get there
all right all right see you guys